ça va être amusant,
un peu large, là, eh
bien, n'est-ce pas un grand verre d'eau, moi,
je suis plutôt un punch hawaïen,
je suppose que tu ne te bats pas beaucoup
en dehors de ta voiture, n'est-ce pas, ouais, je
ne le fais pas  pas besoin de quatre roues pour te botter le cul,
aucune chance que nous remettions ça dans les voitures,
que diriez-vous d'un peu de musique tueuse
[Musique]
c'est un malentendu sur lequel on me
tire dessus depuis que je me
souviens de ma
première habitude, je suppose qu'on dirait que vous l'avez fait
problèmes de confiance ouais tu n'as pas tort belles
pipes mec je dois dire cette note haute
qui est parfait un mot puis-je y aller j'ai
un endroit où être je pensais que tu avais dit que tu
venais au spectacle bien sûr je le suis
juste puis-
je partir après le  montre
bien dans ce cas la soirée est la soirée d'ouverture
étrangère